hi dr. Wallach I am so can you hear me
yes ma'am very well okay okay so I'm
just really a static to be able to talk
to you I've been suffering for quite
some time and I first started out in
September 18th I had a really bad
stomach ache I don't know if I got food
poisoning or what happened but I was on
the toilet with really bad diarrhea
thought I was going to die
wanted to go to the emergency room but I
kind of don't like those places and ever
since then I have had a really bad
stomach ache and I've been to doctor
after doctor which I don't usually go to
and since the stomach pain I have had a
plethora of issues okay we'll stop there
for a minute
what did the doctors say was your issue
or did they give you a diagnosis well
they haven't really I'm still on the
list waiting to go see a gastrula just
wait okay and so what are the palliative
Jim
they said gastritis but you know I just
don't know if you stopped some stuff so
I got to ask you a couple questions you
have any history of skin problems any
eczema dermatitis psoriasis or rosacea
I have rosacea and I also have a rash on
my back that I've had almost my entire
life okay well let's just call it eczema
maybe close enough and then did you ever
have any respiratory problems any asthma
bronchitis as a kid not really as an
adult I've had a couple of tacks when it
gets really really hot outside I feel
like every night okay sure
yes what's it has probable uh she's
definitely got a gluten intolerance yep
and what he wasted and I weigh a hundred
and seventy pounds and I am 48 years old
and I'm also an athlete I am a I play
volleyball and I am a volleyball coach I
play competitive volleyball so Georgia
Tech I have had like you know a migraine
here and there
my life like me every 12 years I'm
taller I'm five seven okay
alright the situation I have had six
migraines in 12 days I've had a cold
where my lymph nodes had swollen up in
my neck I've had extreme joint pain
can't even turn my neck into the
emergency room two or three times my
viral load says that I have epstein-barr
and and a herpes one which I've never
even heard of and some other things that
I can't pronounce just called the site
Tomica Larry
Cyrus okay sure I may and Suzanne weighs
170 pounds she's got her basic
underlying gluten problem she's got
rotation she's got this rash her back
which I'll call examine her lack of
anything else
she has joint problems basic joint
problems painted her joints back and so
forth she also has some virus problems
including herpes and those kind of
things so that means her immune system
is down so what diet would you put her
on and what supplement program would you
put her on to support her body's ability
to maintain repair itself I would get
her on a gluten-free diet obviously
right away nope and no oils and no burn
animal fat and then I would get her to
healthy brain and heart packs and I
would also get around the killer biotic
and B I think I get around the colloidal
silver - okay and what would you do for
the joint stuff she could take some
gluco gel for that and of course some CM
cream for the pain topically
what about sunshine vitamin d3 there you
go two bottles of vitamin d3 capsules
she could take three of those twice a
day
she needs the gluco gel and Charmaine
said Suzanne I'd get to the large 240
count beluga jealously take 15 a day
five of practice lunch and dinner
they're designed to support remote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue just a
vertebra phone makes your phone so and
for the enviros is stuff if you have
herpes on your lips for that sort of
thing you can actually put the clothes
over directly on the open blisters or
ulcers if you have it on a cervix or
something like that where you have
herpes viruses if general herpes
you can put it put the let's see here
put the colloidal silver on a tampon and
it was still in the applicator to apply
it at night leave it in there all night
to get up through the day and do that
every night for a couple of weeks and it
can by actual contact kill that herpes
virus okay give us a call every couple
of weeks we'll walk you through this it
sounds pretty straightforward but your
doctors have missed it actually should
contact the state Medical Association
and the state licensing things and tell
them your doctor's mrs. diagnosis by a
million miles and in a traumatic
position in 30 seconds and his his
assistant the charmaine figured it out
in just seconds